[Music]
all right in exception news and I said
I'm right yeah
never said that where before submitted
by Modelo time a banana was duct-taped
to a wall
sold for 120,000 at Art Basel I saw this
all over Instagram all right yeah so
there's this there was this art which
was just essentially a [ __ ] banana
duct tape to the wall and it was sold
twice so it's amazing well this is
called comedian and so the artist
created this twice and sold it for a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
twice Wow who bought it
that's kind of sexy you were saying the
kind of sex looks like a dick on a wall
exactly the super sale is the people who
did purchase it they were saying like
this is the equivalent like this is
today's the Campbell Soup from oh my god
blinking on his name Andy wall thank you
Andy Warhol so they're saying this is
like the modern day that so that's the
reason why these people who purchased
this banana they purchase it after it
went like popular or did they purchase
it no so it was debuted at Art Basel on
Miami Beach
it's already like a prestigious like
yeah yeah so then that's when so the
artist is Mauricio cut salon cut salon I
already like him is he's a known guy or
something cuz I thought like I can't
just go into art place and be like hey I
got I got a banana and duct tape can I
just use this space right over here he's
an Italian artist and he recently made
headlines because he was the one
responsible for that golden toilet that
got stolen
he's an industry plant I call [ __ ]
he's just like these artists these music
artists like you were like who the [ __ ]
likes this kid but then they blow up and
[ __ ] like that like I don't understand
it like like first of all how many
bananas you have cuz the bananas angst
and France logo for saying the people
who purchased this piece so they got
like a certificate of authentication and
they were they were determined to
continue
we switch out the banana because they
work they were very aware was gonna be a
lot of banana but they just wanted to
like continuously change the banana so
it's living art yeah I call [ __ ]
because the show goes on for like two
weeks or something so they thought of
key people purchased it yeah when you
take it home still is living art yeah so
but somebody walked in and ate one of
them they did yeah I'm sorry I gave it
away
how's this man it was like this is art
maybe some like Oh last one I'm like
dude that's a dope this is a very
artistic way to give [ __ ] like crafts
and like [ __ ] food just stop just put
it over the water and your vitamins in
you just like oh [ __ ] hell yeah I got a
banana again doughnut just duct tape
everything oh the man who ate the banana
his name is David the tuna he's an
artist from Georgia Oh another artist
country not the state and so yeah he's a
performance artist before the
performance piece and he labeled it
hungry artist so I have a video so it's
not it's not a thief it's a hungry
artist yeah so he's like this is we're
artists and we communicate through our
art so I'm just like formants I don't
know if that's hot I can't go to like
the Mona Lisa and piss on it and go
that's my art now yeah I'm a performance
artist true that's the new tip ring bro
yeah it's a prank bro just a classy way
of saying it yeah
this is homie like recording me you
peeled it the wrong way buddy Hayden
that's when I get temple behind we're
just filming what no one there's going
like yo someone go to other artists
right now see I'll do something more I
was looking to get performing that like
I thought he's gonna dance or something
or like you know do something funny
while he's eating I'm just like chillin
eating a banana and then let's so like
that's what he's saying like so the
original artist who did the duck the the
banana with the duct tape like he's this
is a a conversational piece like he's
making a statement by just like taping a
banana to the wall so then he's saying
well his statement of eating it it's
also like adding to the art statement to
the statement he sees it as a yes and
but I see yes and I'm hungry but we all
see it at the facing property delicious
right Oh like in any season starving
artists too so I thought if he's like
doing the method that I think he'd be
like I don't know I feel like he's more
starved he just casually kind of like he
looks like eats a lot
they didn't they didn't charge it with
anything or like he was a responsible
friend they just exported him out
maximally yeah you was saying like I am
prepared
so his he told his friends like have my
lawyer on speed dial
yes I get arrested but yeah like he's
known for doing performance art like
before he did a an anti-putin show in
the Red Square are you ready to die I
don't
that's disrespectful that's like going
in a crib Nate wasn't wearing a red
Dickey suit like what up doe lyke so
that's Phil he's an artist but in my
mind he's just a YouTube prankster
yeah the art world of the art world yes
he's part of Jackass but in Georgia yeah
your country not the state yeah and then
he also did two months before Donald
Trump was elected he installed an SOS
American flag in front of the White
House he's done performance art things
like this
what's cool about that art is it's not
hard to redo yeah set the Mona Lisa off
our fun yeah but then the banana you get
anybody the janitor could come on and
redo it and it's like all cool it looks
just like the original
well according it like with that
certificate that the people who
purchased the installation received they
also received installation like an
installation manual - oh my god like
they could still do the same [ __ ] you
know what I thought they were gonna do
is cut out the drywall and take that
crime like Banksy art oh that's what
they do you cut the drywall l cut entire
like wall day oh how do they take
somebody else's art that he presented to
the people like God don't make that so
[ __ ] up like he puts this [ __ ] like on
public walls so everybody can enjoy his
art cuz he's for other people and then
people come along to take out a whole
wall to put it in their home what she
does he doesn't represent like a
representative who will sell his art
okay so yeah he does put it for the
people but that's this whole thing I'm
cus to why he's so famous but he still
is the one selling his art yeah what
about the guy that owns the building and
the wall a piece of my building what the
[ __ ] no I think he the owner is also
involved in the transfer in the mouth so
you wanna
where did my walk or what
the whole [ __ ] Sukkot of all of this
is light well I guess we got a whole bit
late today be like don't worry about it
performers always get paid no like no
like tips or like their bucket down I
don't know well so after he did that he
posted this isn't Seussical okay doesn't
performance artists get paid yeah you
know what have been dope is he if he had
another picture of the banana like right
here and they were like less than you
know what a disrespect ya know he's
saying that it wasn't a sign of
vandalism or anything it was a sign of
respect that he's like adding no to me
it sounds like [ __ ] piggy back in all
that somebody else's face he draped that
[ __ ] what if someone comes and eats his
eats his photos yeah how does he feel
about I'll tape it yeah it's at a wall
but like backwards so you can't see what
it is dope in my head and smear it all
over his painting and always straight as
it comes back to poops with you you
always get poop in there hey he suffers
from IBS okay does it I have to always
on his mind okay
we have to own it yeah it's a part of
coping so brands have gone in on this
there you go brands and so they're
selling it for a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars and three like 120,000
399 what was the point of that what is
it called it's called like to like
influence or something right the
original art the banana one it was a
minimization the name of the pieces
median all the comedian I was like what
yeah
and then also Perrier I love area by a
lot joined in its muff my favorite water
so people just flavorless bubbles yeah
but you know I'm trying to cut stop
drinking soda so like it gives me that
yeah you pretend that it's sweeter but
it's still bad for your teeth
yeah carbonation yeah I don't even stop
to go straight to my throat that work
yeah that's I hurt yeah but yeah so
because these brands are joining in and
also doing the duct-tape thing like it
kind of proves the original buyers right
like this is kind of like the Campbell's
chicken noodle soup version of today
because everyone's like tight like yeah
they're they're all doing their own
interpretation I want to see a duct tape
company like duct tape a piece of duct
oh that's the matter or like the whole
roll no a piece of duct tape the neck
yeah a very stylish baby just leave with
that just leaving them here yeah
well-behaved baby just staying there
aren't you 29 yeah I'm down or get up
now cool wall get tight throw them up
against it yeah that's fun
yeah I would do it I feel like the way
to become successful as an artist is to
convince rich people that you're dope
yeah and cuz who's gonna pay that kind
of money isn't this like the rich
people's version of like money
laundering that's uh yeah they do that a
lot with art that's why they put they
buy like ridiculous like it's okay we
just need to clean it yeah way to do it
is like let's say you're super rich I'm
super rich and we have our buddy artist
here who's gonna sell us a painting and
then I'll buy the painting and then I
could gift it to you and then you could
gift it back to me and we can move money
that way yeah that's kinda like the
simple way of hiding and moving money so
you guys see that painting on that wall
it's available for $3,000
you want to buy any part of me and they
could blow up artists that way too
because if you blow up an artist value
then whatever they make you could keep
it within your circle
[Music]